[Music]
running on vast amounts of real-time
data traveling through high-speed
networks the cities of the future will
be technologically smart
[Music]
the companies designing these smart
systems say they'll make our urban
environments more livable
they'll keep traffic flowing save energy
and even help keep us safe
countries all across the world are
embracing smart cities
but none more so than china this is
china's newest and most exquisite
blueprint in the new era
that presents the image of a confident
beautiful and innovative china
this is a concept favored by xi jinping
himself the notion of smart cities to
smart society and that has become a sort
of like for me national strategy
to sustain its already high levels of
productivity beijing has pumped an
estimated 800 billion dollars into
high-speed rail autonomous vehicles
smart grids and 5g networks and is
piloting more than half the world's
smart cities
but for many the trade-offs are alarming
high-tech surveillance is already
widespread for chinese citizens and it's
a growing concern for countries who
import these systems from chinese tech
firms china is exporting elements of its
surveillance complex to third countries
through the export of what they call
smart cities by 2030 china is set to
overtake the us and become the world's
number one economy and it's betting that
smart cities will be a key part of that
success
[Music]
the story of china's urbanization is one
without historic parallel
every year 20 new cities are built from
scratch in china more people now live in
china cities and towns than live in its
countryside during the last 20 years
almost every year we have uh
30 million new
new peoples move into the city the
economic reforms of the 1970s drove
hundreds of millions of people out of
rural poverty and into china's cities in
search of work
many would end up in the factories that
powered the nation's meteoric economic
rise today china have 63 percent of the
urbanization rate that means almost 900
million people
in our country is a citizen it's a
residential of the city that's more than
10 percent of the world's population
living in chinese cities
such as the pace of development it can
be hard to get your head around the
numbers china has over 100 cities each
with their own population of over a
million people
despite this china's urbanization rate
the percentage of people in cities is
still some way behind other advanced
economies like the us and japan
but by 2050 urbanization is expected to
hit 80 percent and it's all part of
beijing's plans
everybody knows that china has very fast
the economic growth but the urbanization
play a very important role this is why
china government wants to move promote
that urbanization very much because they
want to use this way to drive into
economic growth we help move our people
from the countryside go to the city
because when people produce the cell
phone they can they can feed more people
create more jobs so this is why china
redesigned the economic systems is very
much depend on the urban edition
that's where smart cities come into it
a new smarter urbanization had already
been designated a national priority in
the national new type urbanization plan
in 2014
as well as encouraging permanent
migration to cities that plan called for
high-speed rail links and other
infrastructure
but to sustain these urban populations
the cities also have to be digitally
advanced
in the communist party's latest
five-year plan five interconnected city
clusters will be rolled out by the
mid-2030s
beijing contends they'll be world
leaders in smart city infrastructure
each will also be home to as many as a
hundred million people
is designed to relieve beijing of
functions not essential to its role as
the capital and provide a chinese
solution to urban problems this smart
city strategy fits into the economic
transformation or the qualitative
upgrade of its economy very well because
smart city and takes all the boxes
innovation technology new economy and
economic upgrade it's a sort of like new
urban utopia or a new urban imaginary
that gives the policy makers in china
some aspirations and some inspirations
as well
in the pearl river delta cluster in the
south is one of the most advanced cities
shenzhen
china's answer to silicon valley used to
be a fishing town 40 years ago
as its population grew 40-fold gdp grew
11
452-fold
when i entered china in january 2015 the
city of saint jean if i'm correct had
around 13 point
some million people living and working
right now if we look at the amount of
people living and working there now it
is close to i think 18 or 19 maybe even
20 million
headquartered in shenzhen huawei is
china's biggest tech firm
when it comes to intelligent cities and
connected cities we have supported the
majority of the world with global and
mobile broadband infrastructure all
these digitized technologies are helping
this industry to also move higher up the
value chain in a much shorter time frame
in 2020 shenzhen deployed next
generation 5g and high-speed broadband
huawei the market leader played a major
role fave has completed a series of 5g
new radio tests the downlink peak
throughput has reached over six
gigabytes per second for a single user
in shenzhen average broadband speeds are
about one gigabyte per second
that's given local companies an edge
when it comes to productivity
the timing of smart traffic lights are
adjusted to improve flow efficiently
surveillance camera systems capture
traffic violations
it sits with a horizontal layer of
mobile and broadband and fixed
technologies to connect it all that's
what makes it intelligent it understands
what it is for it optimizes and it
utilizes all these broadband
connectivities for applications for
people to stay at home and whilst at
home using applications from the
government for example to do this
citizen or residency registration or
transfer from one city to another city
the same for taxation the same for
utilities gas
water electricity and what have you no
more need to go to city hall which is
downtown city center for paperwork and
what have you in the process of all of
this
in return it lowers the burden on
traffic of course because these
millions of people in
five six years time frame added to the
population of sanjin in itself
would also burden traffic
in a tremendous way
but of course these smart cities are
imprinted with the characteristics of
china's surveillance state
the chinese people are being watched in
ways that earlier generations were not
to be honest as a citizen i would used
to be
the
monitoring by so many cameras along the
street
earlier of this year i think
this is a very hot topic a lot of a
debate about can capture my face and
analysis of my my behaviors so so i
think in today the public the awareness
on the data the privacy issues are more
discussion
i think there's a pretty crucial
distinction to make in privacy in terms
of protection of one's personal data
against
companies
misusing it and privacy in the sense of
an intrinsic civil liberty to protect
against overly excessive government
interference into one's personal life
privacy in the first sense there are
actually very robust discussions in
china
there are personal information
protection laws being drafted data
security laws being drafted that are
meant to protect privacy
from company intrusion
as for the privacy in the second sense
there's very little discussion very
little protection from
government intrusion upon one's personal
privacy
if companies are collecting less data
and are being more secure with how they
manage your personal data and your
personal information
that might also limit the ability of the
government to get data from companies
regarding chinese citizens reactions to
ai intruding upon their personal lives
there's a lot more discussion in chinese
social media
chinese blogs than we would assume
in the west
inside china local governments now have
a more effective way to monitor citizens
on a real-time basis under china's cyber
security law companies must store users
data on local servers and decrypt the
data on requests from the authorities a
new data security law which just passed
june 11th is something that chinese
government really cared about and
no one is going to get past this others
worry that chinese companies may share
sensitive information picked up abroad
with chinese intelligence services
huawei has famously been accused of
being dangerous because countries like
the u.s think it could use its telecom
equipment to spy for the chinese
government
huawei denies the allegations arguing
that u.s restrictions aren't about cyber
security but are really designed to
safeguard american dominance of global
tech
china's ambassador to the uk tells the
bbc that britain's decision to drop
huawei from its 5g network is a bad move
for the country
i think uk still has its own independent
foreign policy rather than to dance to
the tune of americans
despite the international scrutiny there
still seems to be a demand for china's
smart city model
chinese vendors have won contracts for
smart city infrastructure in about 50
cities worldwide according to a study by
rwr advisory
most are in illiberal societies
whether such privacy fears are
overstated or not the opportunities are
too great for china big tech to ignore
chinese ceos lined up to pledge their
support for president xi jinping's
recent common prosperity policy despite
the hit their businesses would take as
part of his crackdown on various
industries
regulation of the
technology challenge
and to what extent our behavior our
action even our travel patterns our
shopping and preferences
they are being utilized for commercial
purposes
and i again this is a global issue and
the global concern they're huge you know
market opportunities so they work
together and to promote
what i call the smart city movement in
china
but beijing's dreams of utopian living
could come crashing down the very
urbanization that's led to smart cities
also resulted in vast ghost towns as the
pace of building was too fast for
newcomers moving in the price of the
housing increased very fast this is a
challenge for shanghai beijing like hong
kong no young people go there for the
developers kick-starting these projects
means taking on huge debt so when
buildings aren't filled quickly enough
that can mean companies going bust
chinese authorities are now grappling
with how to handle developers like
evergrand group which now account for
almost half the world's distressed debt
if china's economy takes a hit while its
property developers go bust
smart cities suddenly become a lot
harder to build
despite its orwellian overtones this
convergence between the state and
private tech firms to create smart city
technology clearly has major benefits
smart city apps help china contain the
spread of the covert 19 virus allowing
beijing to turn its economy from
contraction to growth faster than any
other nation and smart city ambassadors
like edwin diender at huawei see their
technologies as essential to our future
it creates more insights in terms of how
and where is this city for example
consuming electricity
consuming power and only with digital
we're able to
create a visualization for that create a
better understanding for that but most
importantly have the principle of big
data analytics to help us understand and
create insights and how to anticipate
but i think the most important one and
the one that is the most sustainable
of course sits with energy transition i
truly believe energy transition is the
next wave of innovation for digital
transformation
eighty-five percent of the carbon
emission
is happening inside the city's geography
so that city will be very important and
how to reduce the carbon addition that's
a smart cities
plan can contribute to
the real question is whether smart
cities will be designed for the people
who live in them or for the governments
and tech firms who run them i strongly
believe that smart city even though it's
built upon technology but it should not
be technology-centric
it's about the livability sustainability
and the the public good and social
inclusion
our cities will thrive in the future by
building and upgrading infrastructure
with technologies that tackle the
biggest challenges of a rapidly
urbanizing world
china aims to be a leader in this field
both at home and abroad
one thing is for sure china's urban
landscape will be dramatically
refashioned in the decades ahead
[Music]
[Music]
you